Is the way you're organizing your
sentences confusing your readers? As an
English professor, I have found that AI
writing tools have been creating some
really bad habits. These writing tools
will not make you a good writer.
Learning to create flow in your writing
will. So, in this video, I'm going to
show you the simple yet powerful hack
for writing that flows that nobody's
talking about, including clear examples
from the author David Foster Wallace,
Amazon product reviews, and even the
sports pages, because good writing is
everywhere if you have the eye to see
it. So, if you want an easy and
completely new approach that transforms
choppy writing into pros that flows,
then all you need to do is remember a
simple German
proverb. Can you teach me to pronounce
German? Hey, sorry about that, but I can
only stick to English here.
Now, in case your German is not as good
as mine, let me break that down for you.
And by the way, if you like learning
about the art and science of expert
writing, then hey, me too. Which is why
I created the newsletter, Writer
Science, where I share quick tips with a
community of writers. Totally free. Link
is down below the like button. At the
most fundamental level, we writers have
two goals. First, we want readers to
understand what we've written. That's
what we're talking about when we talk
about clarity. And second, we want to
tell them something new, something that
they didn't know before. That's what
we're talking about when we talk about
value. So the question is, how do we
make sure that every sentence is clear
and actually gives the reader something
fresh and valuable? When writers think
about how to improve their sentences,
they usually jump straight into grammar
rules, or even worse, they just hand off
their writing to AI. But the problem
with perfect grammar and thoughtless
writing tools is that they overlook
something critical, the psychology of
your readers. And when you learn reader
psychology, you can write sentences that
are clear pathways instead of convoluted
obstacles. To understand how readers
learn new ideas, let me give you a quick
example. Someone once asked Elon Musk
how he learns complicated things so
quickly. Here's what Musk said. One bit
of advice. It's important to view
knowledge as a sort of tree. First, you
make sure that you understand the trunk
and the big branches, the fundamental
principles. Only then can you add the
leaves and the details because without a
strong trunk, there's nothing for them
to hang on to. Musk sees learning as
building a tree of knowledge. Every new
detail you learn is like a leaf that
needs to be connected to a larger
unified structure. And guess what?
Reading works exactly the same way.
Every time someone reads your writing,
they need to see how the leaves of your
new ideas fit with the branches and the
trunk of their own tree of knowledge,
which is kind of hard work. But when
writers make that work easy, that is
when readers can take in a lot of new
knowledge without having to work hard to
connect it to what they already know,
that's what they mean when they talk
about writing that flows. So, if you
want your writing to flow from one
valuable sentence to the next, then all
you need to do is make sure that every
sentence gives your reader two pieces of
information. For the first part of your
sentence, have you ever read something
and thought, "I know this already. Why
am I reading it? Boring." Or even worse,
I have no idea what this means. In both
cases, the sentence fails its only job.
You just had one job sentence to inform
the reader. A sentence is like a battery
in a headlamp. It's got a positive
charge and a negative charge. Now, this
headlamp requires three batteries, which
have both a positive and a negative
charge. But what if you swap them around
so that one battery had two positive
charges and the other one had two
negative charges? Well, it wouldn't
work. Each battery needs to have both a
positive and a negative charge in order
for the headlamp to turn on. And that
light is what happens whenever your
sentence succeeds at informing the
reader. I can't see. I'm blind. So, as I
read to you these following sentences,
just ask yourself which ones actually
inform you, illuminating something new
and valuable. There was a US election in
2024. Donald Trump defeated Camala
Harris. In the 2024 election, Trump's
running mate was J. Dance. Harris's
running mate was Tim Waltz. In the 2024
election, Republicans took control of
both the US Senate and House. In the
2024 election, Trump won
49.9% of the vote. Harris won
48.4%. In the 2024 election, Trump won
77,34,184 votes. Harris won
75,19,616 votes. Only two or three of
those sentences really informed you,
depending on who you are and what you
already know. Some of you are more
informed, so the sentences weren't very
informative. Others knew less, and so
they were informed. But the point here
is that a sentence that gives only old
information, it's like a closed loop.
The reader understands it perfectly
well, but it doesn't take them anywhere.
Only sentences that contain new
information succeed at informing the
reader. But for the second part of your
sentence, let's take a look at a new
example. They have all new information,
but which ones seem easiest to
understand?
666 Turnberry 777
W6566
N666 Turnberry Scotland 1977
TWW6566
JN66 Turnberry Scotland The Open 1977
Tom Watson
6566 Jack Nicholas 6666 6 Turnberry,
Scotland. The British Open 1977. At
Turnberry in Scotland in 1977, Tom
Watson shot final rounds of 65 and 66 to
better Jack Nicholas's rounds of 66 and
66 to win the British Open, golf's most
venerable championship. Each sentence
contains exactly the same new
information, but only one or two are
understandable. Why? Because the
understandable sentences blend new
information, which is the scores like 65
and 66 with familiar context such as
Scotland, the Open, Tom Watson, Jack
Nicholas. A sentence that gives only new
information without familiar context is
like a tile on a pathway that's
disconnected from the others. In order
to reach it, the reader needs to make a
leap. Only sentences that contain some
old information are easy for readers to
understand. If your sentences are all
old news, then your reader tunes out. If
they're all brand new, then your reader
gets lost. So to inform your reader,
then here's how you can apply this
principle in your writing. Always pair
new complex information with something
that your reader already knows. This
balance between what's familiar and
what's new, like the two ends of a
battery, ensures that the reader stays
engaged, understands clearly, and gets
real value from each sentence. But how
much old information do they need? And
where exactly should we put it? To
answer that, I'm going to sell you this
pen. It's a great pen, and if the
following description successfully
informs you about why this pen is so
special, then you are definitely going
to want to buy one for yourself. But
even more importantly, you're going to
see the way that sentence organization
influences reader psychology. For
beginning and intermediate writers, an
excellent pen is the Zebra F301, a very
thin barrel of lightweight stainless
steel. Steel direct from the renowned
mills of Japan is at its core. And to
provide extra durability and comfort,
two major innovations are used in its
outer construction. Two layers of
reinforced plastic are securely molded
to its barrel of steel for increased
durability. A wrapping of textured
rubber grip surrounds its two plastic
layers for increased comfort. Most
standard ink refills can be used with
the F301. The Zebra F series refill
functions best. However, all the
standard lengths are included in the
F301's size range, although the 5 to6 in
range is easiest to obtain. Fortunately,
any of six different colors can be
ordered for the F301. So, did you buy
the
pen?
No. Well, then clearly something went
wrong. When writing fails to inform, it
means either that the reader didn't get
any new information or the new
information wasn't clearly connected to
what they already know. But the weird
thing is that in our pen example, each
sentence actually did contain both old
and new information. So why didn't it
work? Well, the problem wasn't the
information itself. It was the order.
It's like putting the batteries into the
container backwards. You've got all the
right information in there, but it's
just in the wrong order. So now watch
what happens when we keep the
information in each sentence the same,
but just change the order. So for the
first sentence, we'll keep it the same
as the original. For sentences two and
three, we'll just flip them around. And
then notice how this flip in sentence
number three puts durability and comfort
right at the end of the sentence. Now,
we haven't mentioned durability and
comfort before. So, that means we're
putting new information at the end of
the sentence, and that is setting up
reader expectations. I mean, what do you
expect to be at the start of the next
few sentences? Bingo. Sentence 4 starts
by mentioning durability, and the next
one starts with, drum roll please,
comfort, of course. So, the new
information at the end of sentence three
set reader expectations for sentences
four and five. And those sentences began
with old information linking back to
sentence three. Moving on to sentence
six. Now that we've gotten durability
and comfort out of the way, we can link
back up to the original theme and end
this sentence by introducing a new
concept, ink refills. In sentence 7,
that sentence transition is meant to
contrast this sentence with the
preceding one. So, it doesn't really
make sense at the end of the sentence.
So, let's move it in between those
sentences by moving it to the head of
sentence 7. With sentences 8 and 9, they
follow the same pattern. They start by
linking back up to the super theme and
end by introducing a new concept,
lengths and colors. Since we read from
left to right and since we learn new
things by attaching them to what we
already know, readers naturally expect
familiar, that is old information first,
followed by unfamiliar, new information.
If we reverse this order, then readers
have to constantly backtrack to make
sense of what they're reading. The
chains of reference between the ideas
become like a plate of spaghetti with
the sauce underneath. So, what's the
solution? Well, it's simple. Always
place old information at the beginning
of your sentence, followed by new
information. By the way, when you follow
the old to new principle, you create
what's called a clear focus where the
beginnings of each sentence link back to
a single entity, and that creates a
coherent unit of discourse. This focus
guides readers smoothly through your
ideas, helping them understand how each
new piece of information connects with
the larger idea. Which brings us to a
pretty boneheaded piece of writing
advice. Never use the passive voice.
Always prefer active
verbs. The writing mavens online love to
trot this one out. And it's even
enshrined in that Bible of writing
rules, the elements of style, which
tells writers to always use the active
voice. Of course, this is one of the
most common corrections that comes up in
people who use Grammarly and and similar
software. And to be fair, the passive
voice can create some problems. But if
you know how to use it properly, then it
can be a powerful tool for writing
sentences that flow. And this is the
really tricky thing about teaching the
passive voice. As the author David
Foster Wallace says, if you say to
students, never use the passive voice,
you're an idiot. Sometimes the passive
voice is exactly what you want, but not
all the time. And probably not more than
5% of sentences really need to be in the
passive voice. This from a writer who
got people to read a 1200page novel. He
knew a thing or two about writing that
flows. So what are those 5% of cases
when the passive voice is exactly what's
need to make writing that flows? Well,
let's start by following the advice of
the writing mavens. Shrunk and white.
All these sentences use an active verb,
but see if you can spot where it breaks
the pattern of old to new information
flow. The properties of
decentralization, scarcity, and security
make Bitcoin the most revolutionary
currency on Earth. First, Bitcoin is the
most decentralized form of money that
has ever existed. Today, millions of
people, from Silicon Valley billionaires
to broke college students, use it for
transactions. Because of the lack of
central control on these transactions,
Bitcoin enables transactions without a
banker silently judging your spending
habits. Each sentence puts the agent,
now that's the technical word for the
thing that performs the action of the
verb in the subject position, which
means they're a-okay according to shrunk
and white. But look at sentence three.
The active voice forces us to put the
new, heavy, complex information at the
start of the sentence and the old
familiar information at the end. And
that's what's so stupid about
rules-based writing advice. They
completely ignore reader psychology. One
thing I always tell my students is that
languages are organisms. They're always
evolving to become more efficient, and
they'll never keep a word or a grammar
form that doesn't serve some purpose.
And English has evolved to have the
passive voice for exactly this
situation. Since English has a fixed
order of subject, verb, object, the
passive voice allows us to arrange the
sentence so that old information occurs
at the beginning of the sentence in the
subject position. So, if you're tired of
rules-based writing advice from Wright
and the other writing mavens, then
here's how you can use the passive voice
to make your writing flow. First, move
the goal. Sorry for the technical
language, but that's just the quick way
to say the thing that receives the
action of the verb. That's the goal.
Move the goal to the subject position.
Second, move the agent, that's the thing
that performs the action of the verb, to
the end of the sentence in one of these
prepositional by phrases. Finally,
insert the verb to be and switch the
main verb to the past participle, which
becomes the properties of
decentralization, scarcity, and security
make Bitcoin the most revolutionary
currency on Earth. First, Bitcoin is the
most decentralized form of money that
has ever existed. Today, it is used for
transactions by millions of people from
Silicon Valley billionaires to broke
college students. Thanks to the lack of
central control in these transactions,
Bitcoin enables transactions without a
banker silently judging your spending
habits. Old simple information at the
start of the sentence, new complex
information at the end of the sentence.
Das is good. Which reminds me, I forgot
to tell you the meaning of that German
proverb. The one that perfectly captures
the idea of writing that flows,
which of course in German means a
whale's vagina. Actually, I think the
meaning is closer to the beginning and
end, shake hands with each other. But
old to new information flow is only one
of a set of tools that you can use to
hijack your reader psychology. So, if
you want to learn three other principles
for reader psychology, then you need to
check out this video right here because
it's going to show you how to use four
writing hacks that readers love. So, be
sure to go check it out.